the movie begins with Jenna and her
boyfriend returning home after having
dinner with their families however on
the way they get into a deadly car
accident Jenna survives with minor
injuries but her boyfriend is not so
lucky he dies on the spot leaving her
terribly scarred cut to three years
later Jenna is still recovering from her
loss she hasn't even dated anyone
fearing that she will lose them again
one day Jenna's childhood best friend
Renee invites her to spend time at a
Lakeside Cabin she accepts the
invitation and goes to the cabin on a
speed boat with Renee and her boyfriend
Michael they are also joined by
Michael's friend Ian whose Uncle owns
the cabin it soon becomes clear that
Michael is playful and carefree in
nature and is on their way there he
entertains the girls after an hour the
group eventually arrives at the cabin
and meets Ian's Uncle Wade the latter
has prepared some shots as a welcome
drink everyone gulps him down within a
flash but Jenna politely declines and
goes inside to take her medicine however
after a brief contemplation she decides
against taking any pills as they make
you're dizzy and dependent on others
that night during dinner Wade tells the
group about a local festival and reveals
that he has secured tickets for them he
then welcomes Ian and his friends to
come and have a good time there later as
Jenna goes out to play with Wade's dog
she notices him giving Michael some we
Jenna discusses this with Renee and the
latter reveals that Michael has a
drinking and smoking addiction she says
that she has tried to convince him to
quit many times but without success
Renee then asks a friend if she is
having a good time and Jenna assures her
that she is okay and having fun
meanwhile Wade leaves early for the
festival saying that he is responsible
for arranging the fireworks the rest of
the group also prepares to leave but
just then Michael finds a sauna in the
cabin not wanting to pass up such a good
opportunity he convinces the others to
take a steam bath before going to the
festival Jenna is seemingly not
comfortable with this but when her
friends insist she agrees she then heads
upstairs to prepare for the sauna in her
room Jenna removes her late boyfriend's
ring from her neck and puts it safely
with her pills afterwards she goes
downstairs and grabs two bottles of
water before heading inside the sauna as
the room heats up Ian tells everyone
that Wade made the sauna all by himself
it works by heating stones in an
electric oven storing the temperature
for a long time soon everyone begins to
sweat profusely so Ian suggests going to
the lake for a dip however as soon as
they dive into the freezing water they
feel cold and come back inside the cabin
the guys then have drinks in the kitchen
while the girls return to the warmth of
the sauna Soon Michael gets wasted and
he returns to the sauna with Ian there
he asks Renee to accompany him to their
room but she refuses and she doesn't
like to stay around him when he's drunk
she then keeps on berating him so
Michael leaves by himself to have more
drinks and weed after he goes out Renee
expresses her frustration with Michael's
drinking problems she mentions that
whenever they go to a party he always
gets wasted and she has to take care of
him he was very kind and understanding
before but now he has changed however
Ian who is also present in the room
comes to his defense and attempts to
provide an explanation for his friend's
Behavior listen up Babes my friend's not
an alcoholic he just likes turning up
this only intensifies Renee's anger as
she is fed up with constantly looking
after everyone just then everyone hears
a loud noise coming from outside worried
that Michael may have tripped and hurt
himself Renee decides to check on him
however for some reason she isn't able
to open the sauna door puzzled Ian also
tries to open it but without success
Jenna begins to panic and starts
screaming at the top of her lungs
fearing that something bad has happened
Renee quickly calms her down and
inquires if she has taken her medication
but Jenna admits that she didn't take
her pills because she is trying to live
without them soon everyone begins to get
desperate and they yell out for Michael
through the small glass window however
even after multiple attempts they do not
get any response Ian is sure that
Michael is pulling a prank on them until
eventually let them out however Jenna
reveals that Wade gave him weed so even
if this is a prank Michael will forget
that he has locked them inside the sauna
that must be some good weed as for Renee
she remains completely neutral perhaps
because she is about to be cooked in the
sweltering sauna after the three are
done with their many arguments Ian looks
through the glass window and notices
that there's something blocking the door
Renee suggests breaking the window but
Ian doesn't want to start damaging his
uncle's property just yet he insists
that they will find another way out
assuring them that they have an ample
Air Supply he further emphasizes that
their main concern should be the
increasing heat Jenna then notices
something behind the thermometer and Ian
explains that it's a thermostat however
the group can't turn the heat off using
it because the controls are located
outside the sauna the temperature can
only be changed from outside and the
thermostat only signals the heater to
turn off when the desired temperature is
reached therefore Ian advises the girls
against messing with the thermostat in
the next scene the gas suddenly starts
hissing and Ian worries that the
temperature in the room is slowly
increasing Renee grows impatient and she
grabs a ladle and tries to break the
glass window but without success seeing
Renee lose her mind Ian ultimately
decides to break the window himself he
uses a towel and a ladle to pull out a
burning Rock from the heater he then
dumps it in water to cool it down before
grabbing it and repeatedly striking the
window with it it was a badass plan but
the glass doesn't break and His Hands
soon starts to bleed however he doesn't
lose hope and keeps on pushing with
everything he has got Ian's hard work
finally pays off in the end as the glass
eventually shatters allowing some fresh
air into the room they again call for
Michael through the window but he's on
that OG cush so they still don't receive
any response Ian then takes a look
through the window and it becomes clear
that Michael didn't lock them in there's
a ladder stuck between the doorknob and
the raised platform nevertheless the
girls breathe a sigh of relief as the
room gets considerably cooler however
Ian reveals that the heater is going to
turn back on because they had set the
sauna temperature to 185 degrees earlier
so since the window is broken the sauna
will never reach that temperature and
the heater is going to stay
therefore he comes up with a solution he
proposes wrapping the rock with a towel
and using it to remove the ladder but
despite all of his expertise and
determination he fails with time running
out Renee proposes that they should
break the thermostat to deactivate the
heat but Ian intervenes sworning that if
their attempt fails the temperature
inside the sauna could rise to a
dangerous 250 degrees this leads to an
argument between Jenna and Renee and as
the girls continue exhausting their
remaining energy Ian comes up with a new
idea He suggests blowing the fuse of one
of the lights in the sauna hoping that
it would turn the cabin's power off
although the plan is a dangerous one it
is something he has to proceed with so
after a bit of thinking Ian removes the
light bulb and employs a wet towel to
forcefully Jam the socket his aim is to
blow the fuse and cause a short circuit
unfortunately the plan goes horribly
wrong and Ian gets electrocuted as he
falls to the ground unconscious he has
become Korean barbecue the girls rush to
help him but now the situation is
because more dire as the light in the
room is gone the scene then cuts to the
ground near the festival venue there
Wade lets his dog play as he prepares to
set up the fireworks several hours pass
by and the condition of Ian and the
others continues to deteriorate however
suddenly they hear the bark of Wade's
dog they become hopeful again and they
start yelling out for the dog the smart
animal hears their screams and learns
that they are in trouble at the same
time Michael also arrives and notices
the anxious dog when Renee and the
others hear his voice they start
screaming loudly but just then Wade
starts the fireworks blocking the
group's Cry for Help the dog then runs
to Wade and leads him back to the cabin
on the way they encounter Michael and
it's revealed that because of that weed
he passed out on the couch earlier now
he is under the impression that his
friends have already gone to the
festival without him Michael says that
he only woke up after he heard the dog
barking Wade inquires if he's coming to
the festival but Michael reveals that he
already went once but was turned away
because he didn't have a ticket with him
hearing this Wade feels terrible so he
invites Michael to his for some more
weed on the other hand Renee and the
others run out of water and she grows
increasingly impatient in a state of
desperation Renee prepares to smash the
thermostat with a rock but Jenna grabs
her and tries to stop her during the
struggle Jenna accidentally strikes
Renee in the head with the rock causing
her to lose Consciousness Jenna is
instantly overwhelmed with regret and
she cries while explaining that she
didn't mean to hit her friend in
response Ian moves the unconscious girl
away from the heater and assures Jenna
that everything will be fine however
Jenna is shaken by the ordeal and she
continues to explain herself saying that
she was only trying to stop Renee from
destroying the thermostat because Ian
had earlier said it would result in
their death so she killed her but when
she inquires how he knows about this
surprisingly Ian says that he was only
guessing this leaves Jenna stunned and
in a fit of rage she breaks the
thermostat herself lo and behold their
worst fear comes true and the heater
unexpectedly turns on as the temperature
continues to rise Ian's sense of
hopelessness and panic intensifies in a
desperate attempt he makes the decision
to destroy the heater with his own hands
unfortunately this turns out to be an
extremely bad idea as he gets burnt to
death he has now become Indian
Tandoori the heater subsequently
explodes but Jenna miraculously manages
to open the door just in time to save
her own life after escaping the perilous
situation Jenna steps outside and
hydrates herself she then proceeds to a
room to take her medication but
something just doesn't feel right this
is when she realizes that she is still
in the sauna and she was merely
hallucinating meanwhile Michael returns
to the cabin after smoking with Wade
when he doesn't see anyone he smokes
some more and falls asleep on the couch
friggin Michael everybody Jenna Renee
and Ian are still in the sauna with the
latter being dead soon Renee gains
Consciousness and Jenna carries her to
the window to help her breathe better
because of the gas leak genitize two
towels together and suspends them from
the beam using it to keep Renee standing
close to the window she then finds the
source of the gas leak and covers it
with the ladle just before she passes
out following this we're taken to a
flashback which reveals how the problem
arose in the first place it turns out
Michael had tripped earlier outside the
sauna inadvertently knocking some things
over due to his intoxicated State he
didn't clean up the mess and left the
ladder positioned against the door which
later became wedged between the door and
the elevated floor when Renee attempted
to exit the sauna back in the present
Wade returns and notices Renee trapped
in the sauna when he peeks through the
window alarmed he promptly contacts the
authorities summoning both the police
and the paramedics as the survivors are
finally rescued Michael realizes his
mistake and breaks into tears of remorse
he's not going to quit smoking though
the movie ends inside the ambulance
where Renee reaches out to hold Jenna's
hand seeking Solace and support so you
heard it everybody the moral of this
story is not to smoke weed because you
never know when you might lock your bud
inside of sauna and he'll blow himself
up trying to get out subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching